the tool available for East Londonderry
was 4440 1154 total invalid wolf was 124
i all in taylor as the deputy returning
officer for the ace Londonderry
constituency hereby declare that at the
election the number of votes of each
candidate was as follows Gregory
Campbell Democratic Unionist Party DEP
nineteen thousand seven hundred and
twenty three one nine seven two three
Richard John Holmes Ulster Unionist
Party
3135 three one three five Chris McCall
Alliance Party 2538 two five three it
Dermot nickel Sinn Fein ten thousand
eight hundred and eighty-one one zero
eight eight one
Stephanie Quigley SDLP social democratic
and liberal party four thousand four
hundred and twenty three four four two
three Liz Sinclair neg Conservatives 333
3 zero I declare that Gregory Campbell
is return to serve in Parliament for the
East London dairy consumption Singh
[Applause]
and I first of all thank the deputy
returning officer for the magnificent
job she has done both herself understand
we're given that this was her first
election in such a capacity and their
work was tremendous we worked on
yesterday by all the staff was very good
given the bad weather conditions we
injured towards a latter part of the day
could I also thank my election agent and
the election team the election agent
mark fielding who works for me each and
every election we have an election team
in East London Derry
like no other team in any other
constituency in the past 12 months they
have knocked over 100,000 doors in this
constituency and the benefit is there
for all to see in the past couple of
years there have been those in the
nationalist and Republican community who
have singled me out for an attack and
for non-fasting
and for criticism beyond any fair
equitable statement of fact in politics
Gerry Adams two years ago that we had to
break them we're not
mission interview targeted me on the
next day on a radio interview column
Eastwood targeted me on each occasion I
had no right of reply and tonight I need
new right of reply because nineteen
thousand seven hundred and twenty three
people have given the rate of a prior
here and error everyone else needs to
make progress we have said repeatedly we
are prepared to go into government and
build for the future for everyone in
this country this Monday must be the
test of that progress we have difficult
hard decisions to make we have issues we
want to see resolved but were not
prepared to hold the people of Northern
Ireland to ransom to get those issues
resolved Shin fee and have been the
question on Monday is are they prepared
to move on or are they prepared to
continue to hold these the communities
here in Northern Ireland to ransom I
hope we can all learn from the past and
move on to a greater and better future
this party will rise to the challenge
this party has had a magnificent result
a result beyond our way there's wildest
expectations and this constituency women
up from a majority from about 6,000 to
almost 10,000 unprecedented victory the
largest majority we ever had was two
years ago and we exceeded it again
tonight hopefully people will learn
lessons from these votes and move
forward into a brighter better future
for us all for all of our communities
within the united kingdom building a
better future for everybody thank you
[Applause]